نائب الرئيس منافسا للرئيس هي سابقه في
السياسه الامريكيه الحديثه مع تقديم مايك
بانس اوراق ترشحه للانتخابات الرئاسيه وهو
الذي شغل منصب نائب الرئيس السابق دانيل
ترامب لكن ما الذي يحتاجه بانس للتفوق على
ترامب في سباق الجمهوريين نحو الرئاسه
طريق الرجل على ما يبدو ضيق نحو البيت
الابيض وللنجاح بمحاولته للوصول الى
السباق الرئاسي سيحتاج الى تعثر ترامب
والتركيز على ميزه لديه قد تجعله يتفوق
على رئيسه السابق لانه كرجل متزين يتمتع
السياسي القادم بولايه انديانا بتاريخ
طويل من العلاقات الوثيقه مع مجتمعه
المحافظ وهنا كان قد هذه احد اسباب اختيار
ترامبلي بانس ليكون شريك في انتخابات عام
2016 لكن مشاهدينا لانه طبعا المخفف من
حده مخاوف الناخبين المتدينين الذين قد
يترددون في دعم ترامب القادم من نيويورك
والمتزوج ثلاث مرات ولديه قضايا شخصيه
واشكالات كثيره كما نعلم وهو يامل الان اي
بانس من الاستفاده من ذلك التاريخ
الاستقطاب الناخبين المتحفظين للرئيس
السابق طبعا للتصويت لصالحه ورغم ذلك
مشاهدينا سيواجه بانس هذا التحدي مع
مرشحين اخرين يتنافسون ايضا على ذات
الاصول ومن بين هؤلاء المرشحين راندي
سنتوس الذي دافع عن القضايا الثقافيه
المحافظه في فلوريدا تحديدا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات